leute ich kann es kaum glauben ich habe
heute mein internet explorer geöffnet
habe auf youtube ein perfektes video für
eine neue action gefunden und zwar hat
bibi heute am 17 mai 2020 ein video
hochgeladen in dem sie uns ein neues
haus vorstellt deswegen heute dass uns
keine zeit verlieren und wir schauen
direkt ins video rein
vielen dank für die und erstmal was kann
uns wird und wir uns bei diesem video
hier erwarten leute eine sache vorneweg
gehabt mit sicherheit auch schon
irgendeine reaktion von irgendjemanden
auf dieses video gesehen
ich dachte mir einfach nur der
vollständigkeit halber mache ich auch
noch mal ein ich habe dieses video nicht
in seiner gänze gesehen aber ich habe
wohl in einigen gesprächen mit anderen
leuten gehört das baby wieder komplett
ausgebaut hat und ich habe jetzt setzen
auf dem kanal gesehen dass die sich
schon wieder über ein haus kaufen so
also ganz ehrlich okay es wundert auch
nicht bei einer jungen erfolgreichen
geschäftsfrau die mehr millionen als
finger hat eine sache die ich
mitbekommen habe ist was mit
einbauschränken also es gibt wohl
irgendwann irgendwas irgend ein
einbauschrank mir aber das wetter ist
wirklich schön heute am 17
mai 2020 es ist auch gar keinen fall der
vierzehnte november 2020 leute ja der
das behauptet ist wirklich so krank am
lügen das ja der größte bullshit erstmal
louis becker nicht ob das wort im
hintergrund das geht
das war krass alter egos rausgeholt aber
das ist für mich so aus oder also ich
finde es aber so aus als hätte sie so
bist du ein kleiner gezaubert vikarby sd
also wie gesagt ihr müsst ihr nicht
überreden der bbs kranken bäumen so dies
übel reich natürlich hat sie auch
wahrscheinlich eine deckenhöhe davon
vier metern oder so und da ich glaube
weil sie nicht so groß sieht es
natürlich dann auch ein bisschen kleiner
aus
jetzt gar nicht starten soll vor allem
ein paar untergrund so macht man also
wir haben eine wohnfläche von ungefähr
500 quadratmetern auf das ist eigentlich
schon sofort beenden
500 quadratmeter ja gut 500 quadratmeter
villa also ich hab ich habe gehört die
ist wahrscheinlich ich glaube dies in
köln oder sowas nenne es gibt in köln
ein paar stadtteile die sehr sehr sehr
teuer sind und ich habe von irgendeinem
kumpel auch gehört dass in einem dieser
sehr theoretischer teil dieses haus holt
sein soll also die frage dabei ist nicht
ob das millionen gekostet hat sondern
wie viele millionen genau dabei aber sei
ja auch gegönnt wisse niemand ist zu mir
gekommen und hat gesagt du ich bin der
andreas von engel & völkers
wir wollten die einfach mal dieses haus
im wert von 3,8 millionen euro schenken
weil du so netter mensch bist jetzt ja
von ihrem eigenen geld gekauft was sich
ja absurd hast du dir hat ihr business
schwach aufgestellt also das heißt sie
gehört aber ebenfalls liegen ihm hatte
ich doch als sie auf der platte wir
kommen ich meine ich will mal ganz
ehrlich also es ist auch schon eine
beachtliche anzahl an einbauschränken ja
an dieser stelle also schätzungsweise an
diese schränken in höhe von 81 metern
wie so wie ich das auf diesem video
erkennen kann also wirklich brutal hoch
diese eigenes bereich also der allein
das ist schon genug einbauschrank für
keine ahnung was für zwei oder drei
familien 40 meter breite an
einbauschränken dicker ist ja dass das
haupt warenlager von ikea bei denen im
haus ist das einfach wieder aber dafür
einfach wieder
dieser effekt ist so krass vor der
kamera also diese kranke deckenhöhe und
babys körpergröße vergleich dazu ist
halt echt so das wirkt so als hätte also
einfach so gezaubert weiß es eigentlich
schade ist hier läuft fast immer musik
überall in den decken sind lautsprecher
verbaut aber das können wir dank der
lieben geben wir jetzt natürlich nicht
präsentieren
[Musik]
ja krank also also alle allein schon das
gäste-wc nimmt unser aller leben hobbs
leute habt ihr habt ihr schon mal so ein
gäste wie habt ihr überhaupt den gästen
ich habe keinen gäste-wc ich gut meine
eltern haben gäste wird sie muss ich
sagen ich habe kein gäste wird sie habe
gegen gäste wc frage ich die meisten
heute leben dort zu hause
also ich bin ich gestern schon alle mal
raus allein was den finanziellen wert an
geht ja es sei an der stelle muss ich
auch nochmal erwähnt dass das auch an
menschen nicht immer ganz glücklich
macht oder überhaupt natürlich macht
also wenn die bilder eine person nimmt
ja und im eeg die last die qualität der
beziehung zu ihren freunden familie
whatever sorgen was auch immer gleich
und setzt sich einfach nur in dieses
haus weiß nicht ob diese leute nach ein
paar monaten bedeutend glücklicher sind
als vorher
glaube ich damit ja gesagt nicht so oder
so hätte ich schon geil sich hier immer
mit absurden reichtum zu amüsieren
[Musik]
hatte er so ist die qualität hat echt
den arsch wenn nicht so zurück so alles
auf diesem video sagt einfach reichtum
alles diesem video sagt ich wieso ich
glaube ich dass sie so denken würden
oder dass sein werden aber das spricht
so ein bisschen denkt man sich das so
als normaler mensch new york ich lebe
ich jetzt mal weit aus dem fenster und
sagt babys küche kostet mehr als das
gesammelte vermögen der unter und 50
prozent in deutschland
ich kann das kann nicht anders sein
leute auf jeden fall des konzerns 1100
millionär aber gefühlt ist es doch so
leute oder kann so normaler mensch sein
ganzes leben lang schwarz um 10 prozent
von seinem lohn investiert schlaue in
aktien so und dann kommt babys
einbauschrank nummer 31 um die ecke und
es einfach mehr wert ist es nicht so und
hier unten das auch geld muss noch
zeigen einen dampfgarer das habe ich
noch nicht gesehen in meinem leben aber
selbst wenn das geil wie wir so
ungeheuren ist ist also die wollen
eigentlich nicht so flexten ich nehme
den vollkommen ab dass die einfach
halten also den leuten das näherbringen
wollen wir die so leben weil ich einfach
cool finden leute daran teilhaben lassen
wollen weil es ist einfach der krasseste
flex degas wir hatten dampfgarer zu
hause wir hatten einen teller wärmer
juni was ist das
soll jetzt mal rüber kommen weil sonst
die hat er wirklich will ich das
schreiben film der scheiße also die
frage die fein ist wirklich was er mit
diesem ganzen stauraum macht man also
das hat echt krass fiel die müssen so
viel zeug besitzen oder für alle
möglichen eventualitäten ihrem leben vor
plan keine ahnung für den fall dass
irgendwann die die oma den hundertsten
geburtstag feiert oder was auch immer
haben die schon mal 1000 teller einem
einbauschrank oder also also das ist
einzig mir erklären kann so viel
stauraum kann eigentlich kein mensch
brauchen
ist aber das muss ich sagen ist aber
noch relativ menschlich also okay zwei
kühlschränke aber gibt es in manchen
haushalten auch also nur sagen was die
kühlschränke angeht hat sie sich noch
gar nicht so weit von der lebensrealität
der meisten menschen in deutschland
entfernt
das ist schon mal gut was den rest
angeht natürlich schon wirklich sehr oft
[Musik]
angeschaut
das ist ja wirklich so geil dieser
reichtum ist ja einfach nur absurd die
haben einfach noch eine zweite küche
warum ihr habt schon eine küche die alle
küchen die allermeisten deutschen
einfach ob es nimmt
nein nein die architekten von dem haus
denkst du wirklich das reicht nein wir
brauchen noch eine zweite küche das
interessant ist nämlich die
bierzapfanlage wird vom hauseigenen
kernkraft reaktor angetrieben der ist
nämlich in der radius von 10 kilometern
ist unter dem haus und ja es zu dem haus
gehört auch ein team von zehn kern
physikern die rund um die über diesen
reaktor betreiben damit das haus strom
hat und ja das ist so
auch schränke haben wir am erstmöglichen
gelagert ist machen sie schränkt jetzt
nicht auch und hier haben wir noch einen
ich kann leute die strecke müssen zu 80
prozent seines kann es kann nicht sein
das kann einfach nicht sein was soll da
drin sein also wirklich das zentrallager
von care von amazon und keine ahnung
nehmen wir noch vw dazu ja die könnten
vielleicht annähernd so 80 prozent
dieser einbauschränke füllen aber da
kann keine keine normale menschliche
person kann diese einbauschränke das
geht nicht das ist aber viel zu lange
ich es gibt einfach mal ganz schön
ultras fielmann videomaterial oder es
gibt mal durch ihr okay gab ein kleines
fußballfeld im garten das muss man sich
im umfeld von köln auch erst mal leisten
können
gt 63 amg auch 200.000 euro auto das
aber person aus die dann natürlich ist
klar dazu haben wir noch mal macht
ja das ist dann wirklich geisteskrank
ich werde so langsam am ende angekommen
das ist wirklich geil ist das kriegt
also dieser reicht da ist wirklich
einfach absurd
nächstes video dann überzeugen zeigen
euch unser schloss nächstes video danach
wir zeigen euch unser land wenn sie
irgendwann einfach keine ahnung
frankreich oder so einfach kaufen
ich bin sehr froh dass wir diese
jährlich war eingezogen das war wirklich
sehr unterhaltsam ich hoffe auch für
euch ist jetzt schon einige monate her
dass das video hochgeladen wurde ich
hoffe es trotzdem okay für euch leute
geht ihr vorgeschlagen das video hier
und wenn familien in der stadt ausmacht